i love that uh we uh we have a cut out
right behind you andy of a
of a woman who just doesn't seem to be
enjoying the show that much
to be honest with you she's holding a
pop doll
and has like a caricature shirt of us
yeah so she's she's clearly a big fan
she just doesn't love this episode of
this right or she just needs a
medication change that's
always a bug and the guy next to this
guy
well no the uh well first of all him
yeah he's talking about needing a
medication change
yeah and uh even this kind of
i mean it stinks it smells even
the cardboard thing yeah even even the
cardboard smells like sweat
yeah once again i just have to say i am
thrilled that so many of our fans
sent in photos allowing us to make
cardboard cutouts and fill
our audience they really all seem like
uh lovely people
except for one caleb
i just despise caleb
i'm up here working hard trying to
entertain america during a pandemic
and everyone's happy except caleb
thinks he's so much better than me
looking down his nose at the performing
chimp up on stage
oh caleb i think i hate you more than
anyone in this crowd
with the possible exception
of that guy
jordan why why
didn't we put a cutout of jordan in the
crowd
pretending to be an illusionist
andy what would possibly be the point
the only upside
to this quarantine is that i don't see
jordan regularly
we went to the trouble somebody to have
a
cardboard cutout of jordan put in the
crowd to glower at me
yes well actually it we it's funny
because the cardboard cutout is far more
productive than the actual
yeah the action the actual jordan
look at him the actual jordan does so
little
yet the cardboard cutout is just kicking
ass and taking names